el debate de este jueves aquí en
alemania fue una de las últimas
oportunidades para que los candidatos
que aspiran a suceder a la canciller
angela merkel convencieron a los
votantes en particular a los votantes
indecisos
y es que una encuesta reciente estimó
que hasta el 38 por ciento de los
votantes aquí en alemania aún no han
decidido al ciento por ciento porque el
partido votarán en las elecciones de
este domingo esto es particularmente
importante en el contexto actual pues
las diferencias entre las principales
fuerzas políticas en alemania el bloque
conservador los socialdemócratas y los
verdes son de apenas unos pocos puntos
porcentuales los socialdemócratas y su
candidato olaf scholz continúan a la
delantera pero por muy poco la pregunta
principal que muchos se hacen aquí en
alemania después de este debate es
precisamente si el debate servirá para
que armin la sre y el bloque conservador
al que también pertenece la canciller
angela merkel
y recuperar parte del apoyo que han
perdido en las últimas semanas o si por
el contrario los socialdemócratas y olaf
scholz podrán consolidarse como los
favoritos de cara a las elecciones
federales de este domingo